I think some people are going to like
this one too Republican operatives from
Arizona pretended to be communists and
donated to a Democratic congressman to
try and make him look bad and they got
caught and they look really really
stupid these two guys used fake names
they used the name's Jose Rosales and
Ahmad Cydia they walked into the office
of Democratic Congressman Tom o'halleran
they said hey we're here to make a
donation to the congressman in cash they
had $39 and 68 cents in cash and they
wanted a receipt for the donation
written out to the northern Arizona
Communist Party so they go in with this
money the finance staffer for
congressman O'Halloran tells them all
right fill out paperwork and you're
gonna get a receipt by email and when
they were told that the receipt would
come by email and not in in person on
paper they crossed out the email that
they had originally written down on the
form and they put in a different email
address and that rightly made
O'Halloran's finance person wonder why
are they doing that that's sort of a
weird thing to do they did a little
research they figured out that these
were actually Republicans donating to
o'halleran under fake names and this is
the best part Lindsey Coleman who's the
finance director she drove with the $39
and 68 cents in cash over to the local
Republican field office to return the
money
imagine this she walks in and she sees
the guy who claimed to be Jose Rosales
in the office except everyone in there's
calling him Oscar he used the fake name
to make the donation wouldn't be
surprised if you had a name tag on its
that's awesome something else yeah he
accepted the cash back from O'Halloran's
finance director the other guy was also
using a fake name you might be shocked
to hear he wasn't really a mod cedilla
the northern arizona communist party
member spokeswoman for the republican
running against O'Halloran said this is
news to us no one from our campaign was
involved in this juvenile stunt so first
and foremost this is a crime it's
against the law to donate to a campaign
under a false name this should be taken
seriously you know we we hear all the
time about people are voting without IDs
and duplicate voting and whatever barely
happens when it does it's usually a
right-wing
trying to prove a point and when they
get caught which is usually they need to
be prosecuted because it needs to be
shown that it is really serious to do
this stuff and along those same lines
this should be prosecuted as fully as
possible but if you haven't heard about
this tactic before this is a really old
trick
Trump's buddy his henchmen I guess we
would call him who I've interviewed
Roger stone he used to work for the
re-election of Richard Nixon he was
supporting Nixon's re-election in the
early 70s and he started sending
donations to Nixon had a primary
opponent who was very anti-war and Roger
stone started sending donations to
Nixon's primary opponent from the young
socialist Alliance the idea being that
you can later say this is outrageous
Nixon's opponent was taking money from
the young socialist alliance so this is
a very very old trick and maybe the even
dumber part of this is that wouldn't a
true communist there are already very
few actual out-and-out communists in the
u.s. like there's a bunch of Social
Democrats there's some socialists there
aren't really that many communists would
communists really be supporting
centrists in the Democratic Party
especially ones like Tom o'halleran who
used to be Republicans like is that yeah
the Communist Party in the u.s. is going
to support that should be the first red
flag the other red flag would be that it
came from the northern Arizona Communist
Party like how many communist parties do
you think there are in here as oh no yes
there are northern a southern and
eastern Western you don't need all those
if communists are actually out there
donating money in this way I imagine
that they would pick like the farthest
left Democrats that they could find
right you're not gonna say you know who
the Communist Party really needs to
support former Republican centrist dem
Tom o'halleran right like it's it's
stupid to the core and of course we know
that the right needs to do this stuff to
win they need consider all of the
tactics of the right gerrymandering of
course voter suppression whenever and
wherever it's possible that includes
purging people from voter rolls
restricting early voting whatever they
can do
smear campaigns and then in this case
you can add falsifying campaign
donations to the list they need to cheat
to win that is the path forward for them
all you need to do is vote that's it if
all progressives got out and voted
particularly in midterms where the voter
turnout is pathetically low the people
who are trying to influence elections
with fake donations from supposed
communists I hope that they won't have
an impact anyway they definitely have no
chance at making an impact if every
progressive just got out and voted yes
Democrats certainly have the hearts and
minds of the American people it's just
unfortunate that that hasn't been enough
during the past few elections legs on
the issues they still have Republicans
and control of all three branches of
government now even though the left does
represent the views on the issues of a
plurality of this country the propaganda
war has been won significantly by the
right and that's why you still have
people who on paper should probably be
voting for Elizabeth Warren if they were
able to if they lived in Massachusetts
thinking that they are moderate
Republicans and voting for people like
who's a moderate Republican I don't know
a bit Romney Mitt Romney for example
yeah I guess so is he moderate I hope I
don't get a backlash for that I guess
listen compared to like Ted Cruz yeah I
guess we could say Mitt Romney is sort
of a moderate yeah just get out there
and vote please vote that's my message
to you